hello hello uh chase maldon out of
virginia uh for mr chandler
if you saw that anderson silva fight
this weekend what are your thoughts on
it and
do you think he should retire because i
think most of us do
what do you think about just you know
guys kind of out of their prime trying
to fight anyway
good question good question dude a lot
of good questions came in for you man
um you know anderson silva is you know
one of the greatest of all time but when
you watch his last couple fights
it's hard to remember the anderson silva
the greatest of all time i think that's
why i think
what gsp did so well is he was like i'm
done you know
i did my thing crushed it i made my
money i got a
i left a good taste in people's mouths
of a who i am as a man as a competitor
what i accomplished and then i want to
be be out the barry sanders
if you will you know um it's always good
to retire before people think you should
because the fans always want more audio
you know selfishly the fans all of his
fans in brazil
they want more out of anderson silva
keep going keep going keep going but
before you know it you know you lose you
know in devastating fashion
again or you lose that bad again and
then people can kind of forget so i
would like to see him hang it up
even though you know it sounds like he's
going to but i i
i would have said this two three fights
ago as well man you
he's he's a he's a icon in brazil
you know he's a worldwide you know
superstar when it comes to mixed martial
arts he's
i never want to talk about someone's
money or what is enough money or what is
enough legacy or whatever but i feel
like he should have enough legacy should
have enough money should have enough
happiness should have enough
of what he's built to be able to sail
off into the sunset so then what do you
think it is that brings someone back at
that moment like what is it
like if you had to get inside of of his
mindset knowing what it's like to be a
fighter
yeah well and i think that's the
difference and i don't want to bring
other people up but i think there's
definitely been guys that you that
you're like okay
that guy's only fighting because he blew
a bunch of money he needs some money
right he needs to come he needs to make
a paycheck oh if i was in brazil do with
the drugs and women i'd have blown at
all
that's the thing but i don't think i i i
right you're not saying that about him
no i think anderson silva is the guy who
just
i bet he's i bet he's set for life i
could be wrong you know like i said i
don't know the guy
personally but there's a lot of guys
where you say that guy right there
i know why he's stepping in the cage
tonight he needs another paycheck he
needs to
you know nick diaz you mean well yeah
i just made that up all day you know i
mean i don't know i wonder i don't know
how those diaz brothers are doing i bet
they're doing
all right but i mean i know nate nate
diaz did all right when that that connor
fight made a couple million but
you know it's uh it's it's tough because
i'm going to get to that point
eventually you know where people are
like it's time to hang it up you know
but i'm in my mind in my camp with my
coaches it's something you always have
to go back to
your family and your coaches because
you're never going to want to quit
you know you're never going to want to
stop unless yeah that's what i'm getting
at you're never going to want to quit no
even though like a guy like gsp
i mean there's there's him on the re on
record saying he hated fighting like he
he hated he would show up to the arena
and pray to god that the
that the comet would come down and hit
the arena and just end his misery
that freaking that someone would pull
the fire alarm that
there would be a bomb threat that there
would be something where he would just
be like thank god i could go home and
don't have to do this you know he he he
talked about in in and documented kind
of like the anxiety that the guy went
through
and this is one of the greatest of all
time a guy who looked unbeatable at
times you know still does
still yeah i mean still he i think he
could come into the cage right now at
170 and win the freaking title 185
possibly you know so
you never know what's motivating a guy
but you got to go back to your coaches
you know your
your closest of kin your mentors your
family and and then the people around
you that
that know no matter how much how much
more that you accomplish how much more
money you make they don't benefit from
it they just want to see you
happy you know those are the people
that's those that's those are people you
gotta listen to you know good evening
good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one